JEN PERSON: Today we're talking
about Hybrid Work, Cloud Run
CPU, and Cloud Spanner.
I'm Jen Person, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Lots of folks around the
world are working in new ways
across a broad range of
locations and working hours.
Workspace has added new features
to help you work effectively
with your teams.
For example, Spaces
lets you collaborate
while integrating Calendar,
Drive, Docs, and more.
The blog post has info
about new hardware,
setting flexible
locations and hours,
and quickly connecting
with teammates.
So check out the full details.
Cloud Run gives you the
ability to run containers
in a serverless platform
and only charges
for CPU and memory used
during a request or event.
But what if your
container workload
requires background processing?
Well, now you can
allocate always on CPU
to ensure your app
will have access
to the resources needed
while still giving you
the benefit of low ops.
There's a lot of cool
stats around Cloud Spanner
and how you can take advantage
of the strong consistency
and high availability.
If you haven't had a
chance to try it out,
now is the perfect time
with this walk-through.
Follow along to deploy a
sample application on Cloud Run
and Spanner by using Terraform,
and then scale up Spanner.
If you want even more,
check out the repository
of other Terraform examples.
Are you a fan of
the command line,
but wish you could
get better visibility?
Never fear, Katie is here
with a quick git extension--
Git Deploy.
Katie breaks down how
git hooks and extensions
work, and demonstrates
Git Deploy to help
you see more details
from Cloud Build,
by streaming the logs
all with one command.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.